hey everybody thank you very much for
coming to my talk about github actions
i'm b dougie and i'm going to jump in
right now so cool so i'm going to jump
in and talk about github actions
uh there's going to be a lot of examples
uh all that stuff is open source
so feel free to take a look at the top
of the slides uh for the urls and on the
slides that have websites associated
with them
but i'm here to talk about github
actions if you haven't if you've gotten
this far you haven't heard of get up
action it's totally fine
uh github action's the way to automate
portions of your workflow gives you a
piece of
uh github primitives put into one
feature inside of your github
repositories um so
if you have a github repo you have
access to github actions
now github actions is it's the backbone
is workflow automation so
it's a built um built-in feature that
connects a bunch of different primitives
uh at github parameters being github api
authentication web hooks there's all
things that you can leverage
and have access to directly from their
repos so
i'll go through some examples but before
i jump in there i have an analogy i'd
love to share
or anecdote which is basketball uh the
game of basketball it's a sport that's
played in across the world actually i
was gonna say us but it's
it's all over the world and uh it's kind
of like soccer if you aren't
familiar but you use your hands instead
of your feet
and um the option to game is get the
ball in the opposing team's hoop
that's what how you score a basket or a
point now there's a concept of full
court layups where
you have five members on a team and
instead of
that person that takes the ball in
passing it that person this basically
scores the point everybody else sort of
stands around
in the context of coding cowboy coding
is something that comes up a lot folks
who maybe wait for the senior engineer
or somebody else on the team
who has more context on the project to
shoot the ball in the hoop or commit the
code or review the pr
and sometimes it becomes a blocker what
i like to do is find out the best places
actually one thing i like to do when i
contribute to open source is find out
the places where i can actually provide
value and in the game of basketball
there was a book that came out
as well as a movement around hoopanomics
it's when you apply statistics to the
game of basketball
and at this point in the court uh this
is the half court right here
at that point 31 of the shots go in uh
and are made or that are tempted to go
inside the the
basket the hoop and uh that's
hoopanomics
and the way they did is they basically
took all the shots that happened
throughout the entire court
and then they had to find identified
percentages based on that so
this right here you get two points if
that goes in the reason for 31
is because most players are right-handed
so at this point in the court you're
gonna
it's going to be harder to defend a
right-handed shot on that side of the
court
uh it's actually easier to dribble if
you're right-handed to the right side of
the court as well
but there's so many other variables as
well but just note that
if you know you're going to get all your
shots or with 31 percent of your shots
that are tempted made there instead of
doing a full court layup
leverage the team pass the ball from the
one to the two which one
correlates with the player on the team
so the two
being our shooting guard um they're
in position in area 31 to make that
attempt or that shot
and if they missed number three or
number four is going to grab the rebound
or number two will go
rebound so everybody's in a position
everybody's doing their job
and that's what i like about automation
is like it's not everybody but it's
every bot
uh and we'll get into that in a sec uh i
like to actually explain this in ideas
uh for automation through repetitive
tests there's gonna be stuff that we do
all the time every day once a week we're
video pr
uh those are all opportunities for
automation and that's what i love about
github actions uh because you can
actually hook into those web hooks
authenticated um interactions through
the
github ui and make those automations
happen i'll share some examples in a sec
but if you haven't got if you got this
far and you don't have any actions in
your repo
if you just click the tab on your github
repository it will give you some actions
if you have a node.js app or a
javascript app or a deto app or whatever
app
it will just identify that through
heuristics and also because of file
extensions
that you have javascript and it'll
recommend some ci
some npm install some uh scripts to be
able to um
set up ci actions for you uh right out
of at the gate
they look like this uh it does infer
like matrixes so if you do have projects
that um
have different versions of node that are
required to be leveraged in the project
uh you can leverage the matrix uh you
can also run your ci your build
your linting all through github actions
uh
it also gives you access to entire node
environment too as well so
very similar to other ci systems and i
think i i don't want to spend too much
time on
the ci side of the house because i want
to talk about the continuous delivery
but like with good ci systems they kind
of just work this you set them up
you don't have to fix and break or fix
broken
ci's all the time it should be like a in
a place that it works
all the time 99 of the time um
some examples that i have around
continuous delivery is like there's one
thing that i do in my projects which is
i like to have a lighthouse score for my
web projects uh it's something i don't
ever think about
um i only run the lighthouse score
whenever there's a problem or if i have
bandwidth to start
improving accessibility or improving
performance it's something i just don't
think of
uh until again there's a problem the
cool thing with the lighthouse action is
that
it actually gives you a lighthouse score
at the time of pr so
rather than wait for till there's a
problem check the lighthouse score every
time there's a pr
and then we can always work to improve
the project success accessibility or the
progressive web app score and stuff like
that
the other use case i have is my
storybook my storybook.js i have a
project called opensource
and all my components are built using
storybook or sorry they're sort of
hosted
using storybook it's a way for me to
sort of showcase my design
across other folks who contributed a
project i have a front end project
uh it's called opensource.pizza and this
is my design system and if anybody wants
to come in
and contribute they can see my basic
design here
and there's opportunity for improvement
so people can actually
kind of jump in there and get an idea of
how this looks in the code but also in
the ui
i mentioned this but i work at a company
called github you've
most likely heard of it i mentioned it
quite a bit but collaboration tool
uh what we've been doing a great job of
is collaboration at scale we give access
to folks
repository and code across time zone
across
computers across whatever how your
situation your teams are set up
we're here to support that uh this is
the github homepage just shouting out
that this has been updated
in the last uh six months and it's got a
cool little globe but i also want to
point out that
that number is outdated it's actually 65
million developers worldwide and um
i bring that number up because i just
mentioned that i'm a developer advocate
at github
and properly introducing myself my
name's brian douglas this is what i look
like on the internet this is my handles
as well but the 65 million developers
uh helps me with this term which is i'm
a beyonce advocate which
i'm a big beyonce fan and beyonce has a
lot of fans as well
and i like to basically be what the
people are just like the little mermaid
uh i like to hear the questions answer
questions you have a question about
actions about
issue templates about you know all the
stuff within your repositories i'm happy
to
field those and introduce you to people
who can give you answers
um speaking of beyonce i've got this
project called the bay bot
and uh this baybot is a project i i
built
as a joke last year uh but it's a twitch
integration to basically when you're
live streaming
folks can interact with you using this
baybot it's built on javascript and html
and css
pretty basic i've also built this other
in the bay bot i've also built this as a
github action as well
and it gives me the same sort of
interactions but
uh instead it's gonna be in your github
comments uh i built this actually that
issue right there
uh is accessible you can actually test
out the bay bot yourself
right there um but it just responds with
a
a gift of your choosing so it's not
beyonce only you can use a uh
using to get a giphy api you can present
a gif of anything you would like
but what i'm getting at is like a lot of
these concepts i'm gonna bring up uh the
next few slides
we're all open source like feel free to
jump in jump out
leverage stuff for clone that's the
beauty of uh github actions that you can
clone and fork
and contribute the things that you can
start building upon off and
that's what i love about this conference
and i'm super honored to be here again
speaking um about something completely
different than i spoke about last year
but the one thing i want to point out is
one thing that i
had no concept of or ever tried or
attempted to do with my projects which
is generating release notes
um i find this process a little bit
cumbersome
especially as a solo maintainer of a
project i just don't think about
notes and making sure folks are on the
same page
i'm the one that's shooting the the full
court layups and
using this github action which is called
release drafter it actually gives me an
idea of like the commit from
this shaw to that shaw and all the
commits in between and gives me a
beautiful list
of commits that i can share for my team
and it looks like this
this is my open source releases you can
see the pendubot is a
number one maintainer on my project uh
and
all the commits that they did in that
week
uh which is intense depending on you can
slide out a bit um
they're all listed right there and i can
keep track of like okay these are
petabot changes but these are all the
changes from the humans up here
and i'm able to organize that through
release drafter and it's all built on
automation
um also shout out to semantic release
with github actions it's all based on
yaml which i showed
earlier but i didn't call out it was
yaml uh you could run npm scripts or npx
scripts
so if you already have a github token
and npm token you can do your entire
automated release with semantic release
which is
a cli tool that you can leverage inside
your action workflows
so it's not about only using actions but
it's also being able to have access to
uh existing and ready to run node
environments as well
now this is sort of the meat of the
conversation and sort of how i'm going
to round up
this talk is cloud deployments and
environment management which just sounds
like a mouthful but it's kind of the
heart of my cd workflow
i have a project called slaybot and
slaybot
it's kind of like baybot but this one
slays and it's literally the description
it's right there on the right
uh but it's basically a bot but not
another level so it
integrates github api to be able to
whenever someone stars a repo while i'm
live streaming
it will show up on screen it's like
sort of like tongue and cheek and a lot
of the stuff i sort of work on is kind
of tongue-in-cheek
all right so since i have a bit of time
i'm going to add a little
so since i have a bit of time i'm going
to show you a really quick demo of what
slaybot looks like
uh best thing i could show is going into
the repo
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
star the repo itself and on the
above you can see i actually started the
repo the other thing you could do
is you could type in the yoke command
and
beyonce shows up and shows that that i
am hype
in the chat uh this is the sort of sums
up the interaction but let's just jump
back into the slides um
um but i do live stream every tuesday
and friday on twitch.tv
i build git of actions i build open
sauce and i also build a couple other
things
and i like to interact with my community
and have folks like
feel like they're on stage with me but
without needing to be in front of camera
so with slaybot what i do a lot is on
stream
i have to fix stuff for the bot and i
also have to set up staging environments
too as well so i can test things out
so basically you're building the ship
while you're trying to sail it down the
river
exactly what i'm doing slaybot i've got
in my
my environments i've got a staging
environment which i have here you can
see
on the right and i've got the production
employment um sorry the production
environment
and i won't go into a great detail of
this and i'll actually zoom in on that
but basically github offers an ability
for you to set up environments
in your repositories which makes it
easier for the point deployments for
github actions
it's something we shipped in the last
six months so i encourage you to check
it out
i'm able to also highlight in my yaml um
the the environment name too as well so
i have an environment called staging
and i'm also pointing it to this url so
i've got a separate staging url that i
only deploy
whenever if you look on line 42 whenever
there's a pull request
i'm only deploying to staging and it's
the only time i have an opportunity to
deploy staging it's all automated
and i can set up approval so that way
only one staging
is live at a time so that way not to pay
more money
for that and then the other thing that i
do is i leverage this thing called
github script to be able to
have a comment directly in my pr on that
staging url
and the way i'm doing that is again with
github script
this is the actual github script that
i'm using i'm leveraging the github api
again it's part of the primitives for
github actions and i'm able to take that
url
from azure which uh azure i'll show you
in a sec but it's a it's an azure action
web app service that allows me to deploy
to azure from github
and then return a url take that url and
adding it to the comments and that's
this is the the code that i'm using to
have this run it's all open source feel
free to copy and paste or delete
i might not accept your pr if you delete
it though
and the other thing i'm doing is i'm
uploading artifacts so with
this might be obvious but maybe
depending on
this might be your first issue or first
time you've heard of anything like this
before but with azure
it expects a zip file or a zipped
repository to be able to deploy it so
i'm using
this github action which is called web
app deploys it's uh
all github actions are they're just
github repositories you can contribute
open issues
do it as you would like with them and um
what's cool about this is with the
artifacts i could use a github action to
then
build an artifact uh which is my my
repository
upload it to my pr so basically in my
actions tab i can upload an artifact
where i can see
and download the zip and and whatnot and
i'm leveraging this here this is
actually my build
script or my build job basically
uh and you've looked towards the bottom
that's where i'm uploading the artifact
using the action slash
upload artifact v2 github action
i'm naming it node app which if you saw
before it's called node app right here
and then it's just grabbing all that's
in the sort of current directory
and this is my deploy step which i'm
leveraging again this is for staging
um but if you scroll down to like well
if you look down to line
seven which i didn't highlight that's
where i'm getting the web app url from
the azure web app output
uh and then i'm downloading the artifact
and then at that point i deploy it
um so this is this is the the crux of
how i get my deployments to work while
i'm live on the air and streaming
and it gives me the ability to basically
make it a change or a fix or add a
feature
in front of an audience and do some live
coding and it gives me the ability to
do that continuous delivery continuous
deployment so
i don't have a lot of time to go into a
lot of details again this is open source
definitely check out the repository that
i shared earlier called slaybot
i might be the only slave bot on github
i'm not sure yet um
automating storybook i wrote a a blog
post on dev.2
about how i do that so again i can't go
into detail on how this is
this all works but i do encourage you to
definitely
check it out um there is my design
system too as well if you won't also
want to check it out and contribute to
it i
forgot why i have that slide there but
and then finally the lighthouse action
i mentioned in passing this is my
lighthouse score so i'm able to see the
score
in my actions tab inside the logs i
didn't have time to go in the details
about the logs because
i wanted to focus more on the continuous
delivery piece of this
but there i got my logs every time my pr
happens i can historically look at the
context and what's changed
i can even make this a comment on the pr
as well if i wanted to
and it gives me everything i need to do
to basically make this work
also shout out i didn't mention too as
well but you could also have
your urls inside of your workflow
visualizer which i sort of
breezed by uh what you're looking at
here is the workload visualizer you can
visualize your workflow and the steps
as they sort of depend on each other i
also want to shout out that my
github profile it's powered by github
actions i intentionally built a myspace
clone using github actions
in the github profile readme so if you
want to dig into that repo
find out how i'm leveraging uh code to
power by powered by actions to be able
to
keep my my top eight up to date uh
man i wrapped also shout out to my
youtube because
you know like and subscribe but also i
have some github actions tips and tricks
as well so i've got a playlist there
if you're interested reach out if you
have questions because i end up making
those in the videos because it's easy
to have that the point to the folks in
the future
also wrote a whole blog post on how i
built the myspace on my github profile
using actions
check it out and again just try actions
and i hope you found this insightful
uh i'll be around the q a q a sessions
uh so find me
or find the the sessions and i'll be
there to answer questions
all right thank you very much and this
is what i look like on the internet if
you forgot
all right have a good night or a good
day